what's up my babies life rips and this
is episode 172 of congratulations
crazy crazy
yeah dude life [ __ ] and i'm changing
it to like friggin rips because we don't
swear because we're mormon
um we do when i was in high school the
mormon girls liked me because i was a
bad boy but i wasn't really a bad boy
you know what i mean i didn't do drugs
and stuff but all these mormon girls
were like oh he's not mormon you know
what i mean that was the thing
that was how they used to like get back
at their family by like not too much go
for the
major bad boy dude or a black guy but
they would go for your boy
and so um anyway
so probably get cancelled for that so
we're doing uh we're doing it here we're
doing it live it's a fly by the seat of
the pants episode and it's also firing
on firing on all cylinders and it's also
at the [ __ ] nighttime podcast dude
the nighttime podcast is the [ __ ] and
we're already one more minute down we're
59 minutes from collecting bags
life rips man this shit's on shit's on
i'm wearing my mask less and less mostly
just indoors but it's all good how about
people who drive
when they wear the mask what are you
doing that's like being in your [ __ ]
house
with your mascot um
i saw segora had the [ __ ] instagram
where he said look i'm driving like one
of the [ __ ] idiots and he had a
[ __ ] mask on when he was driving
um yeah dude but uh that's that's it
and my [ __ ] dog has got aids all over
his face
[ __ ] yeah dude butters is probably gonna
die dude he
butters looks like the guy from the
goonies with the bent to ear he just
looks like he's just
a breath away from being like hey you
guys dude
he had a [ __ ] eye problem so i took
him to the vet
and when you go to the vet you gotta
wait in the car and then the nurse comes
out and you hand the [ __ ] dog over to
the vet and then the vet
walks it in and then you wait in the car
like a big dumb [ __ ] idiot
and i was and i'm in the car for [ __ ]
one hour
and then they come back and they're like
yeah so he's got an eye infection and
i'm like oh oh
really how did you figure that out
because his eyes all [ __ ] caked up
well why did you figure that out because
it's the only dog i've ever seen with
conjunctivitis
and um and so they were like just put
these drops in it every
three hours and so i did and it moved to
his other eye
yes now it's in both eyes a yes down
on it standing we need a little
oh dude and that wasn't it so we started
putting the drips in the second eye
and then guess what dude oh [ __ ] yeah
dude it spread to his
nose how did it do it
hey stop moving the light around down
there and
how did it spread to his nose dude his
nose looks like a [ __ ] barnacle
so that's bad so his nose looks like
some barnacles and his eyes look like
they're [ __ ] caked up
caked up eyes and [ __ ] nose barnacle
and uh so it looks really bad so anyway
take him into the vet tomorrow and
who knows if it's his last day or not in
the meantime
trash dog chens uh i talk about him i
still call him trash dog
on the on the on the rogan podcast he's
always going to a [ __ ]
superstar uh superstar
hey could you be more distracting down
there i mean jesus christ
um i took trash dog to the [ __ ] um
to the vet because why
well i don't know we found this dog i
told you near target
like it was shopping for some [ __ ]
place match or some [ __ ] uh
and went to uh
and so i don't know all of a sudden he
started wincing and [ __ ] i think he was
probably abused
but i'm a [ __ ] savior so i keep him
and i keep him nice and i don't [ __ ]
you know i keep him real nice and as
frustrating as he is because he shits
everywhere and [ __ ] vomits everywhere
i still hold my cool and i'm like it's
okay it's okay
and he barks and [ __ ] wakes the baby
up and just everything dude and i just
go
okay all right all right gents it's not
even his name i made up a name for him
trash dog scraps [ __ ] rat [ __ ] anyway
um run away dude
so so one day he's [ __ ]
you know you know a dog's in trouble
when they're just like this
what when they look like a [ __ ] uh
um a private uh when they look like
donnie brasco
the [ __ ] johnny depp at the end of
the and end of the movie where he's like
no no no i'm a mafia guy
and they're like what what the [ __ ] you
you wearing a wire
what sorry uh
no i'm a dog it's all good
arf ruff ruff ruff ruff
ruff ruff oh a bone
and uh guys in the van guys in the van
just hearing arf
quieter clyder uh and so
um man imagine being one of those guys
in the van how important you feel and
how [ __ ] dumb you look too
because you're just so cooped up and
you're listening to the guy
who's wearing a wire and you're a
[ __ ] flower van
and uh and so he was just
chilling not moving and my girl's like
something it's weird and i'm just like
oh for [ __ ] sake now you think
something's wrong again you know i i
don't know i don't know
and i'm like no it's fine you know he's
just a dog he'll he'll it'll be fine
he's just being really weird and i'm
like what do you mean
and she's just like i don't know it's
just like he's just like really like
cautious i'm like all right she's like
yeah
i think it's like for no reason just i
think it's like neurological
oh all right cuz you're a [ __ ] vet
dude chicks will just
[ __ ] make [ __ ] up man
i think it's the neurological thing why
you know if i just
so i'm like all right so
take him to the [ __ ] vet and
and the vet's like he pulled his back oh
really is that so [ __ ] neurological
so he pulled his [ __ ] back so she she
gave the vet gave him pills
now i got to give him pills every
[ __ ] however many hours
and he's got like three pills like he's
[ __ ] some 80 year old
uncle and uh they're in these blue
bottles
and i go to sleep i wake up and i look
and there's [ __ ] peel pill bottles
all over the goddamn living room floor
and i go what the [ __ ] and they're empty
dude and this [ __ ] dog this trash dog
ate 500 milligrams of [ __ ] whatever
the hell retinol
is called like it was some [ __ ]
funyuns dude
and he's just and i look back over him
and he's just like this
what uh uh arf it's all good i
i'm a regular dog in the meantime it's
just arf
20 minutes go by earth
everything's fine
[Music]
[Laughter]
nah but he didn't he was chilling and
i'm like all right let's leave him dude
he [ __ ] made his bed dude the dog ate
500 milligrams of retinol whatever the
[ __ ] it's called
and my girl's like we should get to take
him in and i'm like dude we found the
dog
if he it was like the end of the rocky
where dolph lundgren is like if he dies
he dies that was me i was dolph lundgren
on my [ __ ] trash dog
and she was like i know you don't have a
moral responsibility but i am a moral
person and i am a moral and moral and
i'm immortal
and so i was like all right so now i got
to take the [ __ ] trash dog
to the [ __ ] vet to the animal
hospital which is by the way you're a
real
and i'm just like at least nobody's
gonna be the animal hospital maybe the
vet's closed but
dude the animal hospital the line was
longer than [ __ ]
goddamn in and out it was longer than
[ __ ]
what was the christ chicken what's that
place called the christ chicken place
the [ __ ] the place where they don't
they don't believe in gays what the [ __ ]
is it
chick-fil-a those [ __ ]
so scared of [ __ ] and butts
anyway chick it was like the line for
chick-fil-a and i gotta go and i gotta
park and now i'm waiting again
my dog butters with the [ __ ] pink eye
and barnacle nose at home just like i
wonder where the [ __ ] trush dog went
and and my [ __ ] dog is just and trash
dog is just chilling in the [ __ ]
in the baby seat behind my car just
looking at me i'm like that's not for
you get the [ __ ]
out then the nurse comes with [ __ ]
gloves and a [ __ ] mask and she's like
is everything okay i'm like just take
the goddamn dog and see what the hell's
going on
if he's alive or not and they're like
well we'd like to keep the dog for two
days i said how much is that gonna cost
and she's like well
you know you could take it for one day
and i said how much is it gonna cost he
said we'll call you back
call me back it's gonna cost four grand
yeah
four [ __ ] grand like it's some nice
shoes
like it's a blazer i gotta wear three
times dude
i'm not spending four grand on a dog i
found your target two months ago
okay i already got barnacle nose
[ __ ] costing me 800 on some eye drops
that don't work it's just making him
worse
looks like [ __ ] matt damon at the end
of contagion
and so now this dog
uh i gotta i'm like
no bring the dog back well we don't
recommend it well i said well really
well i recommend you giving me my
[ __ ] dog back so i bring the dog back
and now he's just chilling they give him
some charcoal i don't know what the [ __ ]
like he was bad at christmas
and they gave him some charcoal and they
ate it and then he [ __ ] out [ __ ]
black charcoal
they literally are like well his dog if
his poop is black bring him in and i
said you just give them charcoal and
they're like well okay if it's black
like
for the next day after the charcoal [ __ ]
they're like you have to bring them in
the next day and i'm like i'm not doing
that and then you have to also bring him
in on the 11th i said i'm not doing that
so guess what he's fine where is he
where are you trash dog
come here chanzo chenzo come here
come here buddy let make your debut here
come here
come here buddy a good boy he ran away
all right you know
you don't listen to me and you just eat
[ __ ] pain meds
like their [ __ ] skittles it's fine
it's fine
and uh andy and he don't even affect him
dude
he's so [ __ ] he doesn't give a [ __ ]
dude he's like you think pain meds [ __ ]
me up dog no way man
no way man i eat trash i straight up
will eat a milk carton without the milk
in it man
i don't give a [ __ ] dog when i leave
your
house and i run away i eat all sorts of
[ __ ]
leaves trash dunkin donuts wrappers and
also
[ __ ] channel changers if i find that
i don't give a [ __ ] man
bandanas covet masks full of covet i
don't give a [ __ ] man
so i [ __ ] uh lo so i love this dog i
guess i don't know man
i'm a good guy deep down is what i am it
was my point
i took the dog i found to the [ __ ]
thing uh i spent
i think it was 900 on the goddamn guy
and they wanted me to spend an extra
four grand and i'm just like dude
you know
so i ordered this [ __ ] um thing
online
this cup i i have that this
is made this uh
it's really good you got to check it out
it's
emily vandermae v-a-n-d-e-r-m-e-y.com
and you can order your animal's likeness
she draw she writes she draws it on the
cup she carves it into the cup it's like
a coffee mug
it's really [ __ ] cool and she's going
to do one of cenzo
they're good gifts if you do it
emilyvandermay.com
a n d e-m-i-l-y-v-a-n-d-e r m e y dot
com
go there and you can get your animal on
this
mug and i'm gonna get chenzo
trash dog on the mug this way if he runs
away going to [ __ ]
remember him by just having him on my
cup because goddamn i'm not looking for
him again
if he eats more pills he's gone dude if
he's more pills
that's his [ __ ] man so you got to check
that website out it's really good
the way that the way she does it you
have to look
i can't believe how good it is they did
she did one of butters and sam too and
cooper and it's [ __ ] awesome anyway
um check it out uh
[Music]
so yeah
so by the way he's fine thank god i
didn't give him to the [ __ ] four
four grand police thank god i didn't
give him to the to the
uh because he's okay
i know they milk your dude i'm no
conspiracy theorist but i know they milk
you
um what the [ __ ] was i gonna uh
oh uh oh yeah dude i don't know why the
[ __ ] this happened
but i have and i i i try to get the
bottom of it i just try to find it out
today
but like last ep last episode of my
podcast on youtube
um there are certain parts of the world
it's regional it's territorial
but uh where there's like so many ads on
it and i don't know why now
now make no mistake dude i always want
to get the most bags
and if you come in between my bags i
don't care i'm still going to do it
that's the price to listen but i did not
okay this and i don't know why
all the ads are like some people are
like why there's so many ads and there's
like 15 of them dude
dude trust me if i'm going to do that
many ads i'm going to tell you
and i'm going to set it up and i'm going
to be like this is the ads episode your
[ __ ] are going to sit through
all of them
because i'm going to make this cash but
i didn't do that so i'm trying to get to
the bottom of it i'm trying to fix it
i'm pissed off it doesn't happen for
everybody
but uh some people i don't know where in
the world it's happening but it's
annoying as [ __ ]
dude youtube is going through something
different and it happened
uh so i'm trying to fix it but whatever
uh it's all good uh i'm gonna [ __ ]
figure it out um
dude i love how quibby was like
this is that thick man dude i'm getting
real good at knowing what's gonna tank
and what's not gonna tank
like real good like i know that movie
with [ __ ] where
chris evans learned where chris evans
played the trumpet was gonna tank
i knew that lawyer movie with [ __ ]
michael basketball jordan was going to
tank
i knew it because who the [ __ ] cares
and i'm no knockout michael b michael
basketball jordan is a great
[ __ ] actor i love michael barbershop
jordan
and he is amazing
michael barnickle jordan is amazing
and um but nobody's gonna watch that
movie where he's like a real lawyer
and he's [ __ ] popping out to seem
sejacked
you know just like order
just like a [ __ ] superhero order he's
so
jacked he [ __ ] snorts creatine you
know and he's going to be a lawyer i
mean that guy showed up as your lawyer
he'd be like this guy's got to be
[ __ ] joking right
guys that work out [ __ ] lawyers that
work out f wake up at 5 00 a.m and work
out
and um and so
uh but yeah but so quibby was just came
out with
underwhelmingly the amount of uh
what do you call them uh subscriptions i
got it
i don't even know why here's the thing i
got quibby and then i meant to watch it
and i didn't
and and i knew that it wasn't going to
come out
banging out the gates because
and i'm not no knockout i'm sure there's
great [ __ ] on quibby like they've got
really good i mean steven spielberg is
doing [ __ ] on there and
you know they got like cool people who
do cool content and [ __ ] but like here's
the deal people don't
care if it looks good
nowadays it it just reeks of like older
guys
trying to capitalize on the younger
audience
and the younger audience already has
that down
like the younger audience is youtube
it's [ __ ] whatever the
you know tick tock instagram it already
has it down you don't need to make a new
one and try to cash in on it no i
understand that's what they're trying to
do
and they were trying to make it star
driven and okay like they got like
[ __ ] crazy people on this quippy [ __ ]
but like people don't these kids don't
care no you know what kids don't do they
don't look at their phone and go okay
vertical cool
dude i've never once seen a kid holding
a [ __ ] phone like this unless they're
playing a video game
kids watch [ __ ] like this dude nobody's
gonna turn their phone sideways
to watch a [ __ ] movie with that chick
from dark phoenix nobody cares if it's
nine minutes oh yeah
it's but it's bite size oh i don't care
is it skettles
it's nothing it's like
so anyway it came out with
underwhelmingly amount of uh the amount
of subscriptions
and uh i knew that was gonna happen and
you should have checked with me dude
these [ __ ] gotta check with me
man
i know
uh but yeah so whatever
you know what i knew was gonna [ __ ]
do well is six six ten
tomplashi sex nine
templar [ __ ] complete completion 49 dude
i knew
[ __ ] completion 4-9 was i knew
completion fortnite was going to [ __ ]
kill that guy came out he snitched by
the way which is exactly what i would
have done
[ __ ] yeah dude if i get caught
everybody's going to jail but me
just so you know if i get caught
everybody's getting going to jail but me
oh you want to know who was in on it
well there was me saying names
michael
[Music]
that's me saying all sorts of names i go
like this
all the names on the [ __ ] roll of
toilet paper that's who did it
nice doing business with you
so i [ __ ] so i [ __ ]
you know so sucked me off to completion
completion49 came
out
[Laughter]
dude so [ __ ] sucked me off the
completion49 snitch got out and made a
music video
and [ __ ] broke the internet dude
suck me off the completion dude
oh my god man when i first heard
somebody say
yeah dude she sucked me off to
completion i go like this
here are my clothes here's everything i
was going to eat
here's everything i own i'm not a person
anymore
dude you can't just say that and then
[ __ ] expect me to go on living
that's the [ __ ] bird
so anyway dude yeah she sucked me off
the completion bro
okay man what hey dude what blow job
stops it doesn't stop unless you're to
get to go to have sex
later a [ __ ] is always to completion
unless you're going to do sex later you
know what i mean let's go get taco bell
no it's always [ __ ] oops all over
your face kid
do you remember that song give me that
that that nut give me that
that that nut that [ __ ] easy e said
disgraceful
give me that give me that give me that
nut we go where it goes
it does the green acres song because
green acres is the place to be what do
you say
always [ __ ] is the life for me what's
the first part
what's the first part oh yeah so
[ __ ] crass
he goes and some [ __ ] is the place to
be
always [ __ ] is the life for me spread
them legs open
far and wide [ __ ] this [ __ ] just let me
put my dick inside
ah don't you have a dad
don't say that cause i mean dude you
know
this song is called give me that nut oh
so crass 14 year olds loved it i loved
it dude i'd listen to it in my suburban
i'd be laughing man
anyway was i talking about [ __ ]
sucked me off the completion four nine
came out and he snitched and he's
bragging about it and he broke the
internet 42 million views
in 24 hours and of course that was going
to be a hit hey quibby
just [ __ ] do that
nobody's known for their [ __ ] music
anymore unless you're like adele
then you got to do other [ __ ] that's why
it's like
i don't know people ask me to do [ __ ] on
i'm like nah i just want to be a
comedian dude
you know i don't want to do a [ __ ]
zoom comedy show for
[ __ ] sake some guy texted me the other
day hey i did my first zoom comedy show
and i
ate [ __ ] and i was like how do you kill
um yeah but just so [ __ ] bad sorry
off to completion dude
oh wow man
um so yeah i guess we can't play the
video but
i mean dude the guy just got he got his
t what did he i feel like he got his
teeth done in prison
dude the guy snitched he's gonna die how
did this guy
not die yet why would any i get why but
also
why would anybody [ __ ] watch that
music video
like also says the n word so much and
he's not black uh
get him just the overall worst guy
like i just feel like he's just so rude
and bad
and a bad person and just like [ __ ]
during meetings he
shows up late for he sure hey dude let
me tell you one thing for sure
san pleasure fact nine has have
chamflampty
[ __ ] shim plamfy jean 509 has
never [ __ ] showed up to a meeting
first he always shows up 10 minutes late
and he's just like
i'm punching 10 faces before we start
where the face is that i need to punch
how how
the smaller and and and more women the
better
pow pow
uh and so anyway
i didn't watch the music video because
they're not getting my click dude that's
my new thing dude not clicking
i'm not clicking [ __ ] click bait i go
like this
oh all right and then i go like this
whoop
nope i ain't clicking join me in the no
click
with the in the no click [ __ ] zone
man i don't get i don't get clicking on
that [ __ ]
um
takashi blam fine has over [ __ ] 200
tattoos of 69 okay
all good let's see ya hey you're a dark
okay um anyway dude enough of that [ __ ]
i got to do these ads hopefully there's
not as many on the [ __ ] youtube shits
i hit my guy and they're not going to be
doing that
that makes me mad man everyone's sneaky
as [ __ ] you know
ship station uh as folks adapt to this
changing world we are all going to be
buying more stuff online than ever
before
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of the new
delivery culture be ready with ship
station why ship station
well when you're selling online getting
a lot of orders out can be fast and
tough
uh uh it can be uh getting a lot of
orders out fast can be tough rather
how do you keep track of who gets what
it's hard which shipping carrier should
you use
are you getting the best rates that's
why you need shipstation.com
it was hard for me until i started using
shipstation.com it's the fastest easiest
and most affordable way to manage and
ship your orders i do it with my merch
people are like whoa i got this quick so
my guy tweeted me today he said
i just ordered it and it was already
[ __ ] and it just was shipped
the next day that's amazing during a
during this amazing
so my fans always tweet me about how
fast they get their orders and it's
friggin
awesome uh right now congratulations
listeners can try shipstation free for
60 days when you use offer code congrats
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com today
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in congrats
that's shipstation.com then enter offer
code congrats shipstation.com
make ship happen bambi
when running a business hr take it from
me hr
issues can kill you wrongful termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulations
and hr managers salaries aren't cheap an
average of 70 thousand dollars a year
bambi smell spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was
created specifically for small
businesses
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy
and maintain your compliance all for
just 99 a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is uh
available by phone
or email or real-time chat it's awesome
and you're probably like
well what is this 40 gs a month nope
it's 99
a month what come on
go to bambi.com congrats right now to
check
uh to schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
congrats spelled b-a-m and then b-e-e
dot com congrats dude
now let me level with you does it make
me mad that juan fire goes
into the [ __ ] into the [ __ ] google
document of the ads
and changes [ __ ] while i'm giving the
ads and then completely messes me up
yes dude oh it doesn't make me
irate though yes does it make me blood
curdling mad though yes
does he still do it yes
it's all good yeah it's all good
but it freaking makes me mad dude i even
said suck me off to completion and he
laughed hard
and then he [ __ ] does that dude it's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um so anyway dude
uh what was i gonna say about the thing
though
i gotta live my life the way i want man
am i doing what i want enough
am i doing what i want enough that's
what you got to ask yourself dude
because because you got to do what you
want as much as you can impossible
in life and if you don't it's okay
because you got to live for other people
sometimes you [ __ ] a girl and a baby
comes out
sometimes you [ __ ] a guy and you [ __ ]
make it so you live with them and then
you have to like
being like oh who's the guy the who's
the [ __ ] top who's the body you gotta
work [ __ ] out is what i'm saying
and sometimes you're like but i don't
wanna get [ __ ] in the butt it's like
all right but it's your turn or whatever
the [ __ ] it is dude
you gotta [ __ ] live that hedonistic
lifestyle because it rips dude life rips
man
if you make it rip and it's okay if it
doesn't because it's still
it's still i don't know man but
my point is is
sometimes the podcast is good and
sometimes it's bad and i don't give a
[ __ ] and you guys
are with me till the end dude you ride
with me man
you ride with me
i need to be a [ __ ] hypnotist i need
to give up everything and just be a
hypnotist man
and just get people to do [ __ ] that's
what i am oh [ __ ] i realize i'm a
hypnotist that's what it is
because sapashi fanpine was like [ __ ] it
i snitched and then made it money off a
snitching when
that's a bad thing i gotta double down
and be like [ __ ] yeah dude
that's that trump [ __ ] i never said it
video of him saying it that's
interesting i don't know i didn't i
didn't say that that was a different
thing i said
what yeah whatever that is that you
heard that wasn't what i said and it
wasn't what i meant so
your fake news
is what it is my babies watch my netflix
special
no pain it's out streaming on netflix
and then there's other ones too that i
do on netflix
uh that i did on netflix
dude i have a confession man uh
i [ __ ]
you know how sometimes you get the wrong
[ __ ] sent to your house from someone
well that happened
i got sent the wrong thing i hate when i
get the [ __ ] someone else's mail dude
guess what i have a thing
if if uh if you get my mail at your
house
that's your mail that's your mail now
if it's a gift you're welcome
if it's a bill pay that [ __ ] okay that's
how we do it
the postal service works the way it
works
and if you mail something somewhere else
that's the end of it dude
that's what's happened to every single
time i've gotten a jury duty letter
never saw it i mean i don't even know if
i've gotten it
i don't even know if they know i exist
the court
because every time
the [ __ ] post office has sent me
jury duty i guess it's been lost
because i've never seen one
all right it's not that i've gotten it
seen it
and thought oh i'm not going
because i'm a good guy
it's that i've never gotten a jury duty
notice
and that's the truth i'll put my hand
on the on the [ __ ] bible
and i'll say that to a police officer
all right so i hope that person goes to
be the juror for me
all right i hope that person sits in the
[ __ ] jurors box for me and goes like
this guilty
not guilty i listen dude imagine me in a
[ __ ] jury box
i swear to god first of all they would
never pick me
they'd be like so have you ever had any
run-ins with the law and i'd be like oh
i [ __ ] hope i know but i can't wait
well you know one time i [ __ ] they'd
be like you know what we're
already your two guns blazing all right
you're out bye
and they'll be like well why the [ __ ] i
have to wake up at 6 a.m and get here by
nine dude i'm out
in a [ __ ] ripped t-shirt you didn't
even wear the right attire why don't
[ __ ] be here man hey what the [ __ ]
arresting me and then they got to get a
[ __ ]
jury jury duty for me and it's the guy
that got my [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh so this is the guy this is the guy i
got the mail from
um so yeah dude if you get
oh man and if i was ever selected in in
any
of the [ __ ] realm of possibility of
okay yeah we'd like to pick mr uh dalia
i would be in the jury but dude i would
roll my eyes
so much that it would be a loud i would
do it so hard that it would be loud
you'd hear me you you'd be like and okay
and so they'd be like
doing the cross examination so you're
saying mr uh plum
that when you were in the parking lot
there were trees in the way
that's what you were saying between uh
the so-called victim and yourself and
the guy would be like that's what i'm
saying and then you hear me in the back
just be like oh come on dude
like really oh come on sir what do they
even do if a juror acts up
do they stop it all right all right
well he's being a [ __ ] dick that
would be me from the gerbs box
and everyone here knows it because we
talk about it behind when we take a
recess
we [ __ ] talk about it in the jury
room or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
back there behind you judge
we talk about it and even the [ __ ]
baylor shot bailiff shot me a look
look bailiff or the [ __ ] female what
do you call a female bailiff
at the [ __ ] bailiffette [ __ ] gave
me a look
so you do the [ __ ] math but i don't
think you did it
can i get like a [ __ ] pizza or
something i'm so hungry you guys make
meat at the wrong times
dude why [ __ ] lunch lunch at [ __ ]
11 30 really
i eat at [ __ ] 10 30 3 30 9
and [ __ ] 1am and you make you [ __ ]
up my whole schedule dude because
some guys stole the [ __ ] the some
money from a gas station
anyway um so
i oh yeah if you get my mail
that's it if it's a gift it's yours if
you [ __ ]
if it's a bill pay that [ __ ] okay
now i get mail most of the time
it's mine sometimes i get mail and it's
someone else's
and dude i don't give it back to the
person that shit's mine
okay if it's something like okay
wow this person really needs to get it
okay
i'll [ __ ] all uber send it to
somebody but dude
even if it's seven houses or like i
gotta walk down here now they [ __ ] up
that's the game dude the mail is mine
now
okay thanks for these you know shorts or
whatever the [ __ ] people mail each other
guess what i got dude i got
cookies i got cookies
i got cookies from a friend to another
friend
and they showed up on my on my [ __ ]
thing not only was it the wrong mail
because i know the name
by the way dude i'm not going to i'm not
going to tell you who it was
but it was a [ __ ] huge celebrity
and they got their cookies from a friend
that was giving them cookies for a nice
hey you know just thinking of you
on i got it on my doorstep it had the
huge celebrity's name on it
way bigger than me dude
and and it and it wasn't delivered to
the wrong place it was delivered to the
right place because they had my address
on it
so you [ __ ] up cookie maker so guess
guess what dude i ate the cookies
i ate the cookies i ate that big
celebrity's cookies there were so many
of them and i ate them all
sometimes i ate half of them and i ate
another half and was watching the
sopranos and i [ __ ] threw away the
rest of the two because
honestly because i forgot i had them
after three weeks they were a little bit
stale but i ate them dude and i didn't
give them back
and that celebrity is not gonna get
those cookies
okay because that's the game dude
that's the game if you miss if you send
cookies to the wrong
my girl she's like we're gonna make
scones now for the [ __ ]
person so now
we gotta give [ __ ] scones to the
goddamn celebrity i gotta show up
imagine the [ __ ] celebrity [ __ ]
not knowing just
also imagine the other person like what
the [ __ ] we told my dad about it and he
was like yeah you don't do that [ __ ]
he was like what kind of guy did i race
nice like a [ __ ] cookie eater i'll
tell you that much
dude the mail
so i [ __ ] ate the cookies and they
were pretty damn good and thank you
um i'll have to find out who sent it i i
um
i still have the note it was a beautiful
note i read it i read the note and i
and i ate the cookies and uh
they're mine and it's fine and it's
gonna be fine and that person who sent
the cookies is probably like i wonder if
the [ __ ] celebrity got the cookies
and that person has no idea that the
cookies did you ever get my cookie that
you know that i'm sure that didn't even
happen yet because it's not it hasn't
been long enough
uh and they have no idea that
crystalline the comedian [ __ ] sat
in his living room watching the sopranos
eating those [ __ ] red velvet cookies
man
there were red velvet cookies and i ate
them dude and there were also uh
a cookie called the beer cookie and
there's also a cookie called the cupcake
cookie
and there's also a cookie called the
chocolate chip cookie and then it was
also a gluten-free
cookie and i was like yeah right dude
what the [ __ ] am i mormon i'm not eating
a gluten-free chocolate chip cookie
it was a cookie crate was what they're
called
and thanks cookie crate anyway dude
well i gotta make [ __ ] scones for the
[ __ ] sorry
hillary duff it was hilary duff
[ __ ] ate hillary duff's cookies
i know her too which is like i did a
movie with her
and i see her in my neighborhood
sometimes i hate hillary duff's cookies
dude
and she has no [ __ ] idea she has zero
idea that those cookies are even
were sent to her probably or maybe she
does and she's like where's my cookies
and crystalline [ __ ] hillary duff
cookies
and now i gotta [ __ ] make her scones
or some [ __ ]
she also [ __ ] gave me other things
dude hillary she
dropped off like eco-friendly dish soap
and stuff
and it was like so sweet and diapers and
[ __ ] eco-friendly diapers and she was
like
here and i was like oh thanks and
[ __ ] i got her cookies and i ate them
dude like a real piece of [ __ ]
if you ever get my my that's the game
though my dad was like oh now you know
what karma's going to come back around
and that's going to [ __ ] bite you in
the ass and i said dude this is the
end of the karma this is karma getting
[ __ ] her back for some [ __ ]
or the cookie maker i'm sitting pretty
dude i'm a good guy
i ate those cookies because it was my
karmic duty
[ __ ] yeah dude i figured it out whoa
i'm scot-free dude
i'm the [ __ ] cookie monster dude
i'm [ __ ] i'm the [ __ ] cookie
monster dude i ate hilary duff's cookies
jeremy renner take me out
[ __ ] yeah dude red velvet sensational
chocolate chip cookie sensational
birthday cake cookies gluten-free
[ __ ] cookie
[ __ ] that was chocolate chip cookie
but also the [ __ ] other one that i
mentioned earlier that i forget
sensation oh [ __ ] yeah they were all
sensational
runner take me out dude i [ __ ] ate
them dude
i ate them and i went num nom more the
cookies went this way
the cookies went that way dude it was
like sparks flying when a guy's in a
montage of a movie making something dude
rather take me out
[Music]
i figured it out dude that's karma
coming back around don't do bad [ __ ] you
won't get your [ __ ] cookies eaten
change the shot of the camera and it's
all good
dude we lose our minds man guess why
this isn't eaten
cause i ate the [ __ ] cookies instead
kyle [ __ ] german runner take me out
hell yeah dude i'm sweating
because i do work for you guys you know
i work for you guys this is real life i
don't [ __ ] sit around at dilly dally
and [ __ ] around
i work for you guys
you know i'm a sweaty guy because i work
when i work out
i go hard i don't do the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
my buddy is like i do two workouts a day
i was like really i said
yeah what do you do he says well in the
morning i do a really fast walk but i
swing my arms when i do it and i go like
this
you're 48 don't say you swing your arms
for a workout
and then he also does [ __ ] other
things
the second part of the workout is a an
actual fierce one anyway dude
um
what's the [ __ ] ads here we go babies
we're doing more and
[Music]
i do it hey [ __ ] hillary dubs cookies
all right uh well got a [ __ ] great
gotta get my into my [ __ ]
email again because i i lost it i lost
the ads dude
but it's all good man see this is the
stuff this is the raw [ __ ] what you see
is what you get
life [ __ ] rips oh dude
manscaped uh if you're bored in the
house
why not play with your balls right
uh our sponsor today manscaped is here
to make sure your balls are smooth
when while you or your partner are
playing with them manscaped promotes
uh clean hygiene when it comes to
shaving your balls
thanks to their lawnmower 3.0 uh
manscaped is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene and i
do it with the manscape 3.0 and i go in
over the toilet and i just
just a little bit and i come out all the
hairs fall in the toilet and i flush it
and i'm looking pretty dude you know the
perfect tools for your family jewels
uh this perfect package 3.0 kit comes
with the new and improved lawnmower 3.0
waterproof
cordless body trimmer and a ton of other
liquid formulations to
round out your manscaping routine it's
awesome and of course let's not forget
about the crop preserver an anti-chafing
ball dealer and moisturizer look you put
deodorant under your armpits why
wouldn't you put it in your taint or
your balls why wouldn't you do that
those smell
bad okay but now when you have this um
this is a perfect package for your
perfect package do yourself a favor and
always use the right tools for the job
get 20
off and free shipping with the code
babies at manscaped.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code
babies make playing with your balls the
best part of your day thanks manscaped
so hmm
wow dude ren or take me out is good
uh i'm in a good mood
and nobody can stop me man what if you
said that and then killed yourself
that would be [ __ ] amazing i'm in a
good mood and nobody could stop me
dude one time i was at a [ __ ] dinner
with my friend now it was lunch
i was up with my friend and we were four
of us and
[Laughter]
and we were eating and he [ __ ] just
and and we were all laughing he's like
haha yeah and he took a pill
and drank water and i said taking
cyanide and he [ __ ]
spit the water out everywhere
and that's a [ __ ] funny joke for that
ass that you can do every time someone's
just taking pills and they don't look
like a mentioned ticket
dude if you're at a [ __ ] restaurant
and you take pills you got to be like yo
guys i'm gonna take a pill right now you
can't just
[ __ ] casually pop [ __ ] pills in
your mouth and [ __ ]
there's laws
um yeah there's laws dude
suck me up to completion dude
[Music]
what about [ __ ] actually before even
that
uh here's something that i'm not doing
okay and everyone can stop asking me
because i'm getting real comedians
asking me to do this
like comedians that are [ __ ] even
like do headlining gigs and [ __ ]
i'm not and you can stop texting me if
you know me personally
or asking me if you don't on twitter or
whatever the [ __ ]
or dm'ing me to do a
zoom comedy show okay
i'm not doing a [ __ ] zoom comedy show
do you know why two reasons
that's a [ __ ] horrible idea
number one and number two i have
a successful podcast so i have an outlet
for
an outlet for it out loud
i'm pissed whenever i mistake a word i
usually don't go back and say it and
i i usually don't go back and correct it
that's the word now okay out loud
i don't even understand what was i
saying about it what was the word out
loud what was that
outlet outlet outlet dude
i have an out lad i have a [ __ ]
outland
and it's my part it's my podcast
do you understand me dude i have an
outland and it's me pardo cast
sir [ __ ] irish dude
what are words anyway do it i beep like
kanye
so i'm not doing a zoom comedy show man
because it's gonna be [ __ ] awful all
right
i have my podcast it's all set up i'm
i'm up here doing my [ __ ]
dude i got ding ding i got a guy who
texted me nine times do you want to do
one of this
this it's [ __ ] no
i'm fine with doing just no stand up
until stand up comes back round
um because dude
well i don't understand too there's like
well yeah but you already are successful
like these comedians
they're like well we're doing a zoom
just start a podcast dude
just talk [ __ ] vice verse dude
which welcome which is just vice
you know they did a [ __ ]
stand-up comedy in the age of i walked i
i went down to find out stand-up comedy
in the age of social distancing
i have glasses so they went to go
[ __ ] no this is to stay at home
comedy show i kind of don't want to do
material right now because all
my jokes are set bc uh like before
corona
thinking that look it's not even that
these people aren't funny
i'm sure they are funny this is just not
the medium for it
no knock on these [ __ ] these
people are probably talented if they get
on the stage i'm sure they could crush
and i also like feel for these
[ __ ] because i remember doing
stand-ups starting out and whatever i
don't know if these people are starting
out or not
but like vice did a whole thing on
cancelled would you be down to try
just doing it streaming like a live show
like a live show but it'd just be
us doing it to our computer and like no
laughter no audience and no feedback
that's just a podcast so just say it's a
podcast
this guy looks cool i would [ __ ] hang
with this guy
um but it's just not gonna it's not
gonna be
funny if you do
it's not going to be funny if you that's
the thing man everything is different
like i always like i always like
try to make it
like instagram i'm not gonna do
instagram like i'm gonna do this podcast
i'm not gonna do this podcast like i'm
gonna do my standup i always say this
it's all for different mediums some
people like me on instagram they don't
like my podcast some people like my
stand up
they don't like my [ __ ] twitter
because it's different
and it has to be because it's a
different medium if i were to do my
tweets like my stand up my twitter will
be awful
my twitter is awful but you know what i
mean it's like
um
[Music]
you know i i it it's just it's just you
can't do the thing you want to do
so much in this
in this medium that way
um it's also like
okay
rona it's okay to not
be funny like as a comedian
not be rip roaringly hilarious dude when
i started this podcast i didn't think it
was gonna be i didn't know if it was
gonna be funny or not
i just thought it's gonna be funny to me
do you got to do what makes yourself
laugh man
you have to do what makes yourself laugh
that's what i do
that's all i [ __ ] do is and i'm
you know this isn't advice or what but
like zoom this zoom comedy [ __ ]
it's gotta go dude it's not funny
i mean [ __ ] the best comedians can do
it and it won't be good
it's just it's not the medium for it
do a podcast do this this wouldn't work
on stage
this is me bullshitting if i were to
come out and have a thing like i'm going
to talk about this i'm going to do this
material i'm going to do that material
it would be [ __ ] atrocious dude you'd
sniff it in a minute and you'd [ __ ]
hang up on me
that's a phone call but you'd click out
of the youtube man you'd turn it off
spotify you'd say get out of here itunes
podcast
this is the podcast this is not stand-up
comedy
big believer in that man um
anyway dude vice zoom comedy
vice i just let me see let's look up
some of these zoom comedy shows
i'm some of them are my friends i don't
want to bash anybody
these guys look i'm sure they're
successful and funny and [ __ ] and i'm
sure they're good on stage
i i feel for these dudes i get it it's a
rough time but this is not the answer
um zoom let's just google zoom comedy
show
somebody was like dude somebody hit me
up and they were like hey [ __ ] uh
hit me uh you could do a set
and we'll pay you thousands of dollars
and it and it
you know we don't record it and leave it
up it's just live and i'm like dude
you don't think someone's gonna [ __ ]
record it and put it up and i'm gonna
look like a [ __ ] huge
jackass
improv comedy show by eight that's
another thing i don't get is uh
um
i watched first of all i watched uh
middle ditch and schwartz
and it was funny they're funny those
guys are [ __ ] funny
um that's like the best version of that
to me
but long form improv to me
is so weird like it's just
i mean i get that you know people are
uh the people who do it are funny
i don't know if it's for me i want to
try to do long form
improv to see what it is like but i just
don't
they're just like so what's up with the
[ __ ]
give me a suggestion anybody got a
suggestion
and they're like sure police okay all
right police okay
does anybody have a time era they wanted
to be in 1980 all right please
1980 all right cool um does anybody have
an object
a chicken sure sure okay chicken police
okay chicken please i'm already bored as
[ __ ]
i can't see anybody have a [ __ ] name
yeah sure sure uh okay okay
lisa okay lisa okay okay lisa
okay okay listen to this car and a
police chicken and it's
1980 okay does anybody have anything
random they want to just throw out there
a full four okay okay so it's a
it's a police officer lisa and it's it's
a four-le
four four wheeler and a [ __ ]
1980s okay so and see there we go
hi i'm at least i have a chicken i'm a
cop and i'm in a four liter
four-wheeler 1984. and it was just like
eat my [ __ ]
i'm making fun of it dude there's good
versions of it okay
so don't come at me with this [ __ ]
long formula for up it's actually
[ __ ] if you look at the ass cat or if
you look at the upright thumbs in the
brigade
dude no okay
just [ __ ] sure
i don't know cancel me already so i can
just [ __ ]
become right wing you know i want to
become right wing
cancel me cancel me so i can become
right wing in three years so i can dip
out of the shadows
good i have a cough yes
um so
what do we have left dude what have you
left
how many [ __ ] times do we have left i
know i told you that story about one
time i said [ __ ] how many times is it
to my dad and my dad asked
my dad was so pissed off i said instead
of how much longer do we have to go
that much longer till we're there and he
was driving to the toll booth i said ask
the toll guy how many times how many
times is it and he goes like this
[ __ ] chris i don't know how many
times is it to the [ __ ] told with guy
um so uh yeah
i did a zoom [ __ ] thing with my buddy
my buddy [ __ ] asked me to do zoom
with him
and a few fans because so to help him
out i did it i did the zoom it wasn't a
comedy show
i [ __ ] worked out while i zoomed it
dude i do what i do
on the zoom [ __ ] and
i always wanted to know about this guy
who does [ __ ]
oh wait dude d
[ __ ] railman this is what i want to
look up
i've always wanted to look this [ __ ] up
on the podcast there's been 200 episodes
or something so i don't think
that we've done this before
but this guy i found this
so long ago
and this guy
it's called his name is daniel songer
all right
and i found this guy years ago on
youtube
and he does comedy act this is the
original zoom comedy show guy
okay his his youtube is dan poet man
all right oh now this guy
is the most life's unraveling guy of all
time
his wife or partner left him for sure
and
this guy was like great who gives a [ __ ]
i'm starting a youtube channel
and all of a sudden was like i'm a
comedian i'm going to do comedy shows
this guy is a [ __ ] genius by mistake
all right this is his comedy show dude
he's got 267 comedy act 267
we are the people comedy act 266 the
greatest comedy act
story act 265 happy easter
in the name of i don't know story act
258 the irishman these are just
comedy act 246 we the men oh they
already did we the people they did we
the man
before that so that's pretty cool comedy
act
238 condom smile well we got to watch
this is the one we're going to listen to
here we go
comedy so it always starts dude the
[ __ ] video starts always without him
and then he introduces himself and it's
just a shot of like
trees or in front of his garage or on
his deck
and then he'll walk into it and it's so
dope dude comedy
please i am introducing the world to
daniel songer
comedy act 238 condom smile oh
here we go ladies and gentlemen
comedian entertainer
daniel songer he always gets so out of
breath in the first [ __ ] minute
it's amazing wow starts it off by going
like this
comedian entertainer
daniel songer back here with
a condom smile
comedian entertainer daniel songer back
here with a condom smile
duty has condoms taped on his red shirt
in a smile they look used and he's
wearing shorts a guy never wears pants
only wear shorts
so gave up on life and is the [ __ ] still
life's unraveling lost his job
and goes like this fine [ __ ] it i'm a
comedian anyway and then started doing
this wow dude
the guy's face gets so red it says yes
that's it comedy act 238
condoms smile hey you know what guys
i have never been one to go
out to a lady and just say
you know just just even say yo hey i
want to talk
dirty to you you know let alone you know
going up to a lady and say
do you want to do something dirty with
me
you know i just have never been that
kind of man yeah
but when i was a teenager i would walk
up to a pretty girl and i'd say
do you want a screw yeah i'd open my
hand
and there lies a screw
i'm telling you man you don't even have
to open your hand
condom smile condom smile
yeah you don't even have to open your
condom smile the dance he does yeah
you know it's like i love what i love
when the joke
i love when the joke when the punch line
happens and he's just like
hey do you want to do something dirty
yeah
i mean it's just i'm telling you
explosion condom smile
and brought it back call back call back
very good call back okay cool
um let's go to another one dude wow this
guy's in the speedo here we go comedy
act
216 the eligible bachelor
oh wait hold on comedy act 215 [ __ ]
happens rear-ended
mpj didn't take the mpj off it dude
re-title it
okay here we go ladies and gentlemen
backyard
comedian entertainer
daniel songer
oh wow short song wow he dresses like a
rapist for real one
a date rapist hey the way he begins it
always so he goes with his back like
this and then crosses his hands and then
turns around like this and goes
hey wow dude
yes that's me comedian
entertainer daniel songer
comedy act 215
it's your new superhero
yeah that's me your new superhero and
buddy i want to tell you guys about
three great books of poetry available at
dan poetman.com oh he's a poet
three poetry books available at dan
poetman.com
now that's going to give you some
inspiration guys
uh there's song lyrics you know i mean
you can sing along you know
i want to be your
i want to be your man
the hero yeah amen
always ends with yeah
[Laughter]
wow this guy's amazing what is this guy
dan poet man what i'd like to do for you
oh well these are the early ones whoa
2007 he's wearing a [ __ ]
hat that like james cagney would wear
and he's got a tie on
it's called the queen of the thunder
the lightning flashed then i heard the
thunder roar oh he does poetry wow
dude what was the guy who sings those
[ __ ] one fire what was the guy who
sings those [ __ ] imagine of
the paper remember the guy who
sings like that
okay if we try to find him dude that guy
oh my god
that guy has so many [ __ ] i wish we
could find that [ __ ]
this is awesome we're just hanging out
uh daniel songer
i gotta find more of this guy here there
were some of them
videos
down in a damn pod the christmas wow he
loves this red shirt
living hitchhiker you find it
no ladies and gent oh you text it
text it all right here we go this guy is
so great
did you text it oh well naturally text
it
dude you gotta you gotta hear this guy
sing this guy's so great
talk about essay divorce guy okay here
we go
tim burn that's his name wow this guy
okay okay dude
this guy oh wow okay in his kitchenette
timothy byrne this has somehow
55 000 views
you just gotta hear this the most
insecure singing of all time dude
this is the most insecure singing of all
[ __ ] time dude and it's also the best
thing i've ever heard in my life
oh he's sweating so hard already just so
nervous
when i find myself in times of trouble
well mother mary comes to me
same note the speaking words of witness
to term let it be
not one note in one different every note
is the same and in my
hour of darkness she is standing right
in front of me
so off me saying speaking what hurts
witness to um let it be all
the same now let it be
[Music]
anything to anybody not call anybody and
just make toast
there will be an end and then eat it and
sit down
and think about how much it hurts and
then go to bed and the thought before he
goes to bed
[Music]
let it be
this is the real [ __ ] when it goes
you know whenever all songs go higher
songs go higher to [ __ ] knock you out
of the park you know what i mean
this song will be like let me be your
hero baby and then a [ __ ]
you can take my breath away and then it
goes [ __ ] let me be
our hero you know what i mean
i can watch a weather pain
let me be your hero it's racist and so
um
there will be an answer let it be
let it be let the description
[Music]
god bless this [ __ ] i love this
dude
this is a guy i would be friends with in
eighth grade and my mom would be like i
can't be friends with his parents
why can't you [ __ ] pick a guy that's
like here's another song this guy's
doing oh i love this guy dude
i make fun of him because i love him you
understand
this guy oh he's
this is a oh he does it's just a video
of him
saying hello
hmm that was an odd one i don't really
know what to make of that one
okay that was a video he posted
okay here's another one
this is great dude this episode's a
little longer but i'm having a lot of
fun
what's a good song sometimes maybe it's
you
maybe it's you jesus guys keep saying
something over and over again
sometimes so far away please rescue me
now what's this one
all right okay timothy james burns
timothy james burn here again i mean my
renting flight in honduras england today
is the
19th of august thousand nineteen let me
show you second date checking out he's
nine
ted would have the swiper if i gave it
back to her it's the 19th of august in
2018 and the logo is on
uh that's yes so is that ambassador
possibly i'm not sure anyway
so that's what's on television i'm
making this video because i'm sure
there are a hundred videos of the same
thing
about the videos i'm concerned with
something just happened but i've just um
gone to look at my uh boiler which has
my hot water and it seems it's like it's
been uh sabotage there's
actually like a big hole in the um this
is what happened
where there wouldn't be a hole it's like
i've been sabotaged here i'm saying this
because
i'm asked this i'm actually making here
an srs video i'm stuck in this house
42 amateur hill homebush england i'll
show you where it's in the mail i'll
start my pc i'm sure where's
i'm asking somebody now please come here
now there's not today this moment now
this second
come in please rescue me from this this
house i'm stuck in i'll take this house
with these psychos like this thing up
there and these
uh terrorists that are screwing around
this construction
and i feel bad now
dude the
brian's instagram about the [ __ ]
movie oh my god dude
did you see brian cowan's instagram
for of his [ __ ] movie dude
oh my god brian callan and then i'm
gonna go
sorry i'm having fun tonight
uh ins instagram here we go when he
did a movie and he
posted it it's called think like a dog
oh i can't [ __ ] play it on my thing
here we go
this is so funny to me
think like a dog it's about a kid and a
dog that talks
he says think like a dog check out this
movie i shot with mega fox josh de mel
and another guy and directed by yadda
yadda
and the whole [ __ ] thing he's not in
the trailer
and it's on his instagram and then he
hey
and then by the way
a day later posted
guess i posted that i made you guys
watch that trailer
for that my friend's dog movie for kids
i didn't watch it i didn't realize i
wasn't in it
i'm sorry to make are you adults
watch that children's
trailer movie about a dog oh forgive me
i should look i should it's my dear
friend the director dude who cares
here's the thing man
you subjected 856 000 people to watch
that [ __ ] think like a dog thing
they're all adults nobody
is going to see that movie because you
posted it first of all you're not in the
goddamn thing second of all
kids don't follow you man you're 52. yes
the whole thing is reeks of 52 year old
he posted the [ __ ] preview of think
like a dog a movie about a
talking dog with a child
is not in it and then makes an apology
video and then left the video
up the guy's insane the guy's
unbelievable
bro it's the funniest [ __ ] ever all
right i'm done man
just remember [ __ ] let it be he let
it be
let it be let it be
speaking words of wisdom let it be
so check out tim burn and [ __ ] dan
poet man and youtube
uh you guys are the best you can text me
at uh
eight one eight two three seven
i'm trying to figure out my live dates i
don't know what's going on with this
covered [ __ ] um
but that's it man uh watch no pain
and all my stuff on uh on
netflix and then there's also that white
male black comic you can watch this my
first special
um but you guys thanks for listening and
subscribe to my channel dude
uh and uh i really appreciate you guys
thank you very much you guys are great
renter take me out
[Laughter]
thanks
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
dot to completion